[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy
hablaremos con carlos eduardo pérez
asesor científico de france 24 y médico
infectólogo de la universidad nacional
de colombia doctor
las cepas británica y sudafricana del
corona virus especialmente contagiosas
se propagan rápidamente la variante
detectada inicialmente en reino unido-
ha sido localizada ya en 50 países y la
sudafricana en 20 según la oms que
señala que este censo además
probablemente está subestimado que tanto
deben preocupar a las autoridades en
todo el mundo estas variantes
las variantes van a suceder no ahora si
no están sucediendo desde siempre es
importante recordar que la variante es
distinto a una cepa y estas variantes
pueden tener la capacidad para ser más
efectivas o menos efectivas estas
variantes que se han descubierto se
contagian más efectivamente pueden
suceder que hayan más variantes que
después se suceda lo contrario o también
en peor ya nos mencionaba dr que es
diferente una variante y una cepa cuál
es la diferencia en qué consiste ente
cepa mutación variante
una mutación es un cambio en el genoma
entonces el genoma es el código de
instrucciones cambia se llama una
mutación esa mutación puede representar
dos cosas si son muchas mutaciones se
forma una cepa diferente es decir el
mismo nombre del virus pero
completamente distinto de la forma anti
génica o si son pequeñas mutaciones
cambian linaje una variante es como
decir todos somos colombianos o todos
somos argentinos digamos eso hace parte
de los linajes pero si cambiamos por
ejemplo nuestra test de piel y somos
morenos pues entonces ya será una cepa
distinta en eso tal vez es una forma
para poderlo entender bien y ante el
avance de las variantes doctor los
gobiernos se precipitan para comprar y
administrar lo antes posible las vacunas
cuando se sabrá con certeza si estas
fórmulas que ya funcionaban para el cob
y 19 también protegen contra las
variantes
la buena noticia es que las que están
actualmente estas vacunas ya
certificadas funcionan contra la mayoría
de las variantes es decir que las
vacunas que hoy se están aplicando
funcionan contra las variantes y es
probable que algunas variantes no sean
susceptibles a la vacuna por eso es que
mantener la vacunación y la protección
al mismo tiempo y una vez se reduzca el
número de casos el número de personas
contagiadas va a haber menos
probabilidad de variante menos porque
nos circule y puede desaparecer pero eso
se va a tomar un tiempo y porque tenemos
que trabajar en paralelo y qué pasa si
las vacunas no protegen contra las
variantes o contra alguna variante de
doctor
se reformulan como eso ya sucede en el
virus de la influenza cada año se tiene
que reformular la vacuna para ver las
variantes y poder tener la vacuna nueva
para poderla vacunar cada año es
probable que si no reducimos la carga
viral como esperamos todos tengamos que
reformular las vacunas con una
periodicidad de tiempo por eso la
importancia es de vacunar pero seguir
con las medidas de protección en
paralelo para disminuir la
transmisibilidad que variante es la que
más podrían tener más los epidemiólogos
las variantes que mencionábamos al
principio a la sudafricana y el reino
unido- pues son las más importantes pero
cada país voy a tener una variante o no
sabemos las para pasar las variantes que
más nos hacen preocupar son las que
aumentan la transmisibilidad o las que
aumentan la virulencia es decir la
capacidad de enfermar y agravar una
persona por eso se monitorizan
constantemente y es importante que
tengamos en cuenta que entre mayor
transmisibilidad mayor número de casos
mayor para el día que aparezcan nuevas
variantes ese sería el peor escenario
doctor si no lo es cuál sería el peor
escenario hablando de variantes cuál
sería el mejor solo nos queda un
minutito
el mejor escenario es que si disminuimos
la transmisibilidad hay menos casos y
menos prioridad de variantes no
solamente el alejamiento disminuye el
número de casos sino la probabilidad de
las mutaciones por eso en la medida que
se incremente la vacunación y
mantengamos el aislamiento vamos a
disminuir no solamente el número de
fallecidos sino la probabilidad de que
haya mutantes virales o que las mutantes
que hay es se diseminen por eso el
mensaje positivo es que si mantenemos
las medidas de protección la vacunación
va a ser mucho más efectiva mucho más
rápida
muchas gracias doctor carlos eduardo
pérez él es asesor científico de france
24 y médico infectólogo de la
universidad nacional de colombia muchas
gracias a ustedes por estar aquí con
nosotros siga en france 24 y cuídese
mucho del cobi 19 y de las variantes del
coronavirus
[Música]